[Music]
it is now my pleasure to welcome our
third speaker
dr sujatha sunil dr sunil
is a group leader of the vector born
diseases group at the international
center
for genetic engineering and
biotechnology dr sunil
take it away good morning
uh one and all i'm dr sujata sunil
a group leader of the vector-borne
diseases group at the international
center for genetic engineering and
biotechnology new delhi
and uh today i'm going to talk about the
infectious disease epidemiology
in the current times and uh try to bring
in concepts of
uh what is the relevance of the
growing infectious disease in the
present communicable diseases that are
also existing
so as for your definition um health
disease and medicines
uh so health in its broader sense can be
defined as a state of complete
physical mental and social well-being
and not merely the absence of disease or
infirmity
whereas disease is defined as a
pathological process
that is the deviation from the
biological
norm and medicine is the science or
practice of the diagnosis treatment
and prevention of disease health
translation is defined as the shifts
that take place
in the patterns of disease and causes of
death
and these the health transitions can be
put up as two parts one is the
demographic transition
that involves the population dynamics
and the epidemiological
transition that describes the disease
pattern of a path
of a population during the demographic
transition
so when we talk about uh epidemiological
uh
transition stages um especially
in developing countries uh ranging
from the early 20th century to the
present times
the early 20th century and prior to that
was burdened with a set of factors
that played a major role in disease
dynamics
they were communicable diseases which
could be pandemics which could be
endemic um reproductive morbidity was
high
mortality was also high nutritional
deficiency was
prevalent coupled with for sanitation
and housing poor personal hygiene
high child mortality high disability
adjusted life years as we call as
uh loss as we call as dali was
uh was the contributing factors for
death and the health statistics
in the early 20th century and most of
them were
preventable disease burden
then during the 40s 1940s and until the
1970s
there was a rapid change basically in
the mid 20th century
which was witnessed by a recession of
epidemics which led to
the later
intervention or the later transition
which had its own set of burden which we
call as the
triple health burden which comprised of
an unfinished whole set of communicable
diseases
reproductive morbidity nutritional
deficiency
rapid population growth and there was
also a rising new set
of cardiovascular diseases malignancies
diabetes stress aging and diseases of
the elderly
accidents emerging and resurging
diseases
which was also coupled with lagging
health care
because this health system and the
medical training were
ill-suited for the rising chronic
diseases
it was also continuing a few diseases
that needed immediate
attention and there was a defined
need for long-term care for the
geriatrics
the disabled and mentally ill
while this transition stages had an
impact
on the life expectancy
as we see so the initial the first
transition stage had a life life expect
expectancy of about 30 years
which progressed to about 45 years
and now we have a life expectancy as
much as
70-year plus so
these eras of in epidemiology
could actually be differentiated into
into three eras that was defined by
the predominating or the dominating
issues
at that era which was
called as the myasma that where you had
for sanitation statistics
which was the greater part of the 19th
century and
which was followed by the germ theory
which was
mostly the infectious disease
epidemiology
which most of my talk in the later parts
would be
concentrating on which comprised of the
19th century through the first
half of the 20th century and what we
currently call
as the black box or the chronic disease
epidemiology
which was in the later half of the 20th
century
so if you're going to talk about how
these were connected with one another
we here we speak about the age of the
pestilence in the famine
which was the poor use of ecological
resource or lack of social and
economical capital
and which led to the next part of the
the age of the receiving panamics which
uh was a a product of increased
economic growth increased use of
ecological real
resources which finally led to
the age of the chronic disease that is
the improved
medical care and social determinants
that's influenced health
but what was important in each of these
eras was
there was no specific distinction from
one fall or rise of a specific either
and each of them with the dynamic
process over time
so if you're going to talk about the
whole world healthcare status
the global status we find there
are several countries that follow
certain categories
which encompasses all these kinds of
eras
simultaneously for instance the
developed countries have
a specific set of uh belong to the
category one
where they have highly developed
healthcare infrastructures
where simultaneously there are the
category five countries
with the least developed healthcare
infrastructures
and these are directly correlating
to if you're going to study the
statistics we are
directly correlating to the rise of
infectious disease epidemiology
versus your chronic disease epidemiology
or
definitely it is a combination of both
these in epidemiology that plays a major
role
so when we come to the correct current
challenges in combating
infectious diseases at least as of
um the early 2000s what we did see was
there was an decrease in the incidence
of infectious diseases
at the same time there was an increase
in the non-communicable diseases
and if you are going to talk about the
the
um the different kind of
non-communicable diseases
we could even say that it was
categorized or it could be clustered
entirely around
trauma or diabetes or coronary heart
diseases
or cancer so what happens
and what was the reason the challenges
with combating in fish infectious
diseases
in the background of these
non-communicable diseases
it was that more pathogens were
identified than the drugs that were
being developed
one death in three of the 54 million
deaths worldwide
is from an um infectious cause
what started off as a boon or a wonder
drug against infectious diseases that is
the antibiotics
also turned out to be a huge villain as
they turned into become
antibiotic resistant and became super
leading to superbugs increased
human travel also attributed to a great
level to the challenge that in combating
infectious diseases that we have an
ongoing uh example as we speak now
and advancement in modern uh medical
practices such as development
in invasive technologies also had their
own
difficulties in increasing or increasing
the
amount or the number of infectious
diseases that were being
deduced or that were being detected
this uh is an um
slide that depicts the re-emergence of
the infectious diseases in the 21st
century
and you can see that they comprises of
broadly two types
we are talking of re-emerging or
researching
uh infectious diseases that are coming
up
almost all across the continents over
the globe
and at the same time we are also seeing
newly emerging
unheard of unknown of infections
which were previously not known of
i'm not even going into the thing of the
deliberately emerging diseases that will
come up
as where as we of bio warfare that
uh that we keep sharing about
and if you want to take a subset of
these
infectious diseases um for instance
when we talk about
the pandemics since the 1918 since we
are talking
in an age of pandemic right now
we say that most several of these
pandemics are coming
at post your the beginning of the 21st
century
and they have contributed
a lot to the way the infectious biology
epidemics of epidemiology
has been studied
if you're going to look into the arbor
viral diseases in the 21st century
the three main thing we immediately look
upon
are the dengue chicken lumia and zika
and what we do see
is that most of them that these
this is the the way that they have
progressed
since 2010 and we can see that there is
a distinct decree
increase in the incidence of these argo
viral infections in the 21st century
even though we do see some of them even
after
2010 this was the existing data because
the start of these arbor viral infection
increase that started way back
in the mid 90s or early
2000s and that has contributed mainly
because of travelers
um travelers as well as
and that is then resulted in um
specific diseases
now when we go the case um that i would
like to bring about to explain the way
the
epidemiology of infectious diseases
especially our global infection is with
respect to
studying the work that we have done uh
primarily on
epidemiology of chicken dunya
so as a brief introduction about what
the disease is
chicken dunya is an emerging disease of
considerable public health importance
in india as well as in the global
scenario
it occurs in two phases the acute fibril
phase and the chronic
arthritic phase caused by the chicken
linear virus the infection is generally
not life-threatening and has a mortality
rate of less than 0.1
however it causes high morbidity with a
major impact on the dally
and is a serious public health concern
because
you lead you there is a huge loss of
productive years of an individual that
contributes to them
to the countries the economy currently
there are no vaccines or antiviral
treatment available
uh and the the disease is
symptomatically treated with
uh antibiotics and or with non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs with or without
combination to steroids
which has its own potential side effects
so what happened why did chicken dunya
come in the first place it was very
prevalent in the 18th century
in the 19th in the middle 19th century
even in india
and after the 70s it completely
disappeared from
the the whole uh the scenario in the
public scenario worldwide
um so what happened what why
what caused the re-emergence of this
disease
so the facts are historically the
mosquito
it is the egyptian was the preferred
vector for disease transmission
and the virus is known to exist as three
genotypes
mainly the eastern central and the south
african phyllo group
over here and the african phyllo group
and the asian group
however in the two in 2005
there was a single point mutation in the
envelope protein of one of the genotypes
namely the
ecsa genotype that caused the virus to
change its preference
of vector transmission
in the vec uh it is alpha vectors became
the
preferred vector for transmitting this
disease
and this resulted in the main was the
main cause of the
pandemic which occurred in 2005 that
originated in large union
and spread to the rest of the globe
and so if you see the global incidence
of chicken dunya when it first struck
this was what was the global incidence
of chicken dunya in 2006
and this is what is the status as in
2019 where we are only talking about
local transmission and we have not
included cases of the imported cases
uh that would definitely increase the
number of
the amount of incident that is happening
um and what is also important of
relevance with respect to
chicken dunya is with respect to india
is that india happens seems to be the
hub of chicken dunya spread because
it houses both the vectors ages
egypt as well as alpha peters and the
various waves of transmission that was
seen if uh chicken the
virus uh in the last 15 years was mainly
because of where uh where india and
india contributed to the transmission of
the disease
so if you're going to see the status of
chicken bunya in india
at the time when after la reunion the
disease was first uh detected in
maharashtra
in 2005 and quickly it spread to the
southern parts of the country
and by 2009 809 the whole of the
southern part of the country
was having a huge outbreak
outbreaks and epidemics of chicken dunya
what was noticed was during all these
outbreaks
this outbreak was caused by these
egyptian and not alopectus however in
2009
the involvement of eddie's algopictus
was also witnessed
in two states and india but surprisingly
after that
we there hasn't been any case reported
of alpha pictures involvement and
all the transmission after that has been
only because of
egypt because we do not see the mutated
form of the virus
anywhere in the indian subcontinent and
as of date
we have as many as 20 states and
union territories that have been
infected with um
that has been in that witness uh chicken
dunya outbreaks
almost every year and uh the epidemic uh
the
the disease also undergoes goes through
this pattern of
being endemic in for several years and
then
it reaches an epidemic potential and
then it goes back to
being endemic in its occurrence
so we have been we as a group in our
research
laboratory have been working on uh the
evolution
and the divergence of this virus in
india and also try to understand the
uh the epidemiology of the virus in the
country and those factors that
attribute we have our clinical
sites and the data from
these clinical sites is what i'm going
to present and also explain the concept
of
how the virus might have evolved since
its
first initial operation 2005. so this
was the study pattern
where we recruited patients uh from
these uh
both these clinical sites and we under
and
we subjected the patient's information
uh samples to various kind of analysis
which involves studying the viral load
looking at the neutralization status
uh correlating the neutralization status
and the viral load with disease
progression
with the initial acute phase disease
progression and the post-acute phase
disease progression
and also look into the various kind of
phylogenetic analysis of the various
kind of strains that could be
um that could be circulating in this
in the country at a specific point of
time and what we do see
is what we did find was a
higher initial viral load during the
acute phase of illness
had a poor prognosis of the disease an
early zero conversion to utilizing
antibodies had a better prognosis
and different geographical regions had
distinct pattern of utilization
depending on the circulating viruses
that were there
and the viruses were of course
phylogenetically different
um next we wanted to see what was the
status of
whether the virus was able to coexist
with other infection
and since owing to the overlapping
clinical infections
of bending we evaluated the presence of
infection of chikungunya in the presence
of dengue
and what we did see is that there was
a very high incidence of infection of
chicken lunia with dengue patients which
also had
distinct clinical presentation of these
mono infection in
fashion patterns um and us also
there were distinct metabolites uh of
in case of mono infection versus and
co-infection
uh rest of the co-infected uh group of
patients
uh so there was a hidden burden of
chicken bunia in confirmed dengue cases
distinct clinical features that could
provide information of co-infection
thereby
have a better disease management and
patient management protocol and distinct
metabolites regulated
in mono and co-infection patients
so next we wanted to also identify
what was the molecular basis of
these viruses and these virus strains
that were circulating in the country
for this we established several uh
different kind of molecular tools
that involved whole genome sequencing
and further identification of
um molecular signatures uh analyzing the
samples
looking for recombinants amongst these
samples and correlating with the
clinical aspects
of clinical information that we have
derived from the samples from
uh what we did see was there was very
distinct
features over the years we collected
samples we've been collecting samples
from 2010 onwards
and we've been analyzing it in the
longitudinal manner over years in
different
different areas what we do see is that
they are
constant reintroduction of strains into
the country
from 2010 onwards and recombination
events
are seen in clinical isolates
and we do we do see that certain
mutations are positively selected over
the years and between regions
and distinct dispreferences were
observed in distinct in strains
between epidemic and episodic
samples so that brought us to the
question
so are they differences when there are
epidemics or outbreaks that happen in
large scale at different time points
so for this we analyze two outbreaks
that happened in 2010 and in 2016
uh in delhi and we performed several
analysis on them and what we do see is
that these two outbreaks present
with distinct clinical outcomes and
differences in the neutralizing capacity
of the binding antibodies had a direct
impact on release progression
in the two outbreaks
so when we are going to look at it with
respect to its impact on disease
presentation
so this was the we mapped
all the various factors such as
the clinical symptoms the binding
antibodies
the the syrological factors the
neutralizing capacity the varying load
the the visual analog score or the
arthritic index of the patient
over the disease and of the two outbreak
we do see that that the two the disease
presentation was different in the two
outbreaks
where the 2016 the disease resolved much
faster
as opposed to the 2016 uh outbreak
patients
were affected by the 2010 uh 2010
outbreak
and this was directly because of the
neutralizing capacity of the antibodies
binding antibodies in the early stages
in the
very first few days of the disease
and when we looked into the genetic
makeup or the genetic determinants of
these two outbreaks we see that they
were distinct
pathogenic difference in uh
in the way the viruses were
impacting the disease and this could be
directly attributed to the
genetic makeup of the viruses so from
this what we can
conclude is what what we could conclude
was
chicken punya is a huge public health
concern in
india and the co-infection of
chikungunya and bengi
is a reality um in our country
the co-morbidity with chicken vegeta
results in severe disease
outcome and statistics information such
as
viral load neutralization utilizing
patterns and different kind of viruses
that are
circulating have a direct impact on the
disease presentation and disease
progression
in case of uh chicken linear virus and
there were
also distinct genetic determinants in
episodic and epidemic strange very
obvious so
what is the relevance of all the work
that we had done in chicken dunya
with respect to the current epidemic
pandemic so
all these questions that we had asked in
our the the story of chicken dunya
they all can be and should be
evaluated in case of safe scope 2
also for instance this is the global
distribution of
uh severe acute respiratory syndrome
coronavirus 2
um nicknamed as subscribe 2
or illusively
and what we do see is the molecular
epidemiology
is coming up with so many different
plates
it's a mishmash of the evolution of
virus
thanks to modern technologies for
evaluating the virus the generation of
so much of
the whole genome sequence information
and also what we do see is
that there are specific
point mutations that could be directly
attributed to the infectivity
or the effectiveness of the virus
in humans as we see this is the
information we got as
as obviously i think that um that
it was seen that there is a specific
point mutation
that was able to show significantly
higher
infections with a specific point
mutation
so um the next part
apart from the virus apart from the
virus
is the host response to the virus
what we have seen is
coping 19 seem to be affecting the host
response seems to be a
extreme drastic effect ranging
from the impact it can have on
the heart the blood vessels the kidney
the brain the lungs the intestines
and what also we see is
that these are having
an home orbit or a condition of the any
of these
organs are having a very major
negative impact on disease property
and so
the kind of information that we get
are being increasing over the time
but what we also see is that commodities
are playing a very major role in the way
the disease is being presented and the
way the disease is also getting resolved
and which leads us to
more and more questions like for
instance
how fast is the virus exactly mutating
and what is the exact impact of the host
response on virus evolution
and what are the comorbidities and
severities of
kobe 19 what are the genetic
associations that we can come up with
respect to the host and the and
the virus but what is most important
enough major concern
is the noise versus signal in the
prediction models that have been coming
up
in the last six months ever since or the
eight months that we have seen the
disease actually
the since the start of the epidemic and
which raises which
raises questions of whether we should
change the way
we have to evaluate the communicable and
the
non-communicable disease that we are
having right now
so as a final conclusion what we do what
we would
what we are seeing is in the existing
um the background of
the john theory the
black box what we are also seeing is
that there is an age of the re-emerging
pandemics
in the backdrop of chronic diseases
non-communicable diseases
that would change the way we looked at
infectious disease epidemiology
and as the title also says maybe there
is a change in the
the paradigm of the disease communicable
as well as in the
non-communicable disease plants so
um acknowledgements are due to
um all my collaborators and my funding
agencies
uh who have uh supported uh our research
over the years and this is
thank you for the time and for the
opportunity mark
thank you very much